大家好 今天台灣股市又大漲特漲
昨天由低到高拉了1000點
最後翻紅
今天還可以再拉600多點
我想要問大家
台股連2天大漲1668點
你會不會 等一下喔
你會不會覺得穩了
這是大家最想要知道的事情
穩不穩
第二件事情
明天凌晨輝達財報
那這個輝達財報
會不會優於預期
優於預期會不會利多出盡
優於預期沒有用
股票會不會漲才是重點
我獨家告訴大家
第三個 最近不是趙建銘
跟陳幸妤的吵吵鬧鬧
據說就是2300萬的育兒基金
2300萬這個錢沒有歸還
如果早就買0050了
有人說早就買0050
他兒子說買0050早就翻倍了
真的是這樣子嗎
這麼好的投資標的
那為什麼有些人賺不了錢
這三大獨家消息 我一次講個夠
大家好 我是摩爾投顧投資長
郭哲榮分析師
也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
應該說也是唯一140萬粉絲的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
台灣股市今天又漲了
我有沒有說你不要擔心
而且我覺得大家很幸福
你現在活在台灣
治安又好
真的治安好啊
大家譬如說韓國
不好意思 最近還有留學生命案
濟州島幾千人不見了 15人不見了
連日本治安也不好
國寶還有人潑油
那不是 那是台灣人跑去潑油的
真的 台灣人不應該分彼此
但是台灣人去外面不要丟臉
這個扯遠了
治安不好 台灣很幸福
治安好就算了
股市
不好意思 又好得要命
我們來看一下股市
你們很幸福 來看一下
不投資台股投資什麼
不要羨慕人家外國月亮比較圓
來看一下
韓國股市上半年漲很多
現在都不行
一蹶不振
自從那一次股災過後
所以我昨天說了
我說台灣股市為什麼資金動能減少
因為政府主管機關
有系統的 慢慢的
不要讓大家借太多錢
資金成本有到3% 4% 5%的
大家就不想借錢買股票了
這樣最好
資金成本增加
資金動能減少
股市就會跑到大戶裡面的手法
我說昨天是大戶買
輕舟已過萬重山
隨便拉就會拉上去
韓國股市就是因為太多散戶受傷了
去買槓桿ETF
台灣就沒有那麼多人
台灣的分析師
不好意思 我講話很臭屁
其實看我的節目多少
我常常跟你講不要用融資
其他的分析師也不敢講那麼大聲
你聽不聽得懂
不像韓國很多網紅會跟你講
很大聲說借錢
我最不屑這種事情
我說這種事情不能做的時候
一般的網紅 一般的分析師
也不敢大肆宣揚這個事
所以台灣比較沒有
借錢買股票這個問題
所以你看經過這個股災後
台灣股市現在比韓國股市強多了
都快創歷史新高了
現在已經45000了
離歷史新高大概只有2400點
扯不扯
你看日本股市 有沒有看到
日本股市看起來拉起來一點點
可是日本股市
他的幣值 他的日元一直在貶
所以投資日股還是不如投資台股
這是台灣股市跟日本股市的差別
我們來看一下
我每天一定先講總體經濟
再講股票
我才不怎麼樣
我很不屑老投顧
10幾年前很多分析師這樣子
只講股票漲停
我最不屑
我說老實話
摩爾投顧的分析師都經過考核的
你聽得懂嗎
就像我這樣講 我們培訓分析師
我們都自己培訓
大部分啦
我要講都花非常多的精力
非常多的時間
我們是要求很嚴格的 好不好 來
我不是批評
可是我們不會批評
某一家投顧的特定分析師
我不屑做這種事
我覺得這樣很沒水準
我覺得沒有意義啦
我只是要告訴你
我們跟別人的差別
一定先總體經濟 再講股票
這是很簡單的邏輯
天天講漲停板
然後總體經濟不會 你相信
這個不能這樣講
好不好 你知道嗎
我一定講總體經濟 講這些東西
來 大盤
台灣股市也是一樣
總體經濟還有一些各國股市比較
台灣股市 講漲停
我問你一件事
今天長榮快跌停
陽明跌停板啦
那些看漲停說漲停的分析師
今天要不要講
要不要講嘛
我問你嘛 要不要講
看到航運股漲就講了
我就說了 因為我有20年投資經驗
航運股我也七進七出
之前還有網友亂留言
那一看就是同業的
馬上回留言以後他馬上刪掉
哲哲 航運股讓人家賠錢
我說我記得沒錯的話
我七進七出最後是賺錢走
我這麼多粉絲你知不知道
你們講話要實在
你不能某一段時間賠錢
就好像我是混蛋一樣
所以我20年經驗
我知道航運股8月
萬聖節 聖誕節 感恩節
這些時間怎麼樣
10月 11月 12月開始了
所以你要提前兩個月運送貨櫃
所以8月底運價起來是正常的事情
他只是一時的行情 一時之選
那不代表9月運價會提高
所以陽明你看拉起來
我跟你講說不要去追
他強任他強 清風拂山崗
為什麼我今年績效那麼好
我跟你講 我前陣子
5月的時候 4 5月的時候
每一檔股票
每一個進出 所有會員都賺錢
那時候是這樣
現在沒有到那時候那麼好啦
因為陸續有人參加會員
行情也比較難做
但是今年績效
我認為 我個人認為
我還是傲視群雄
因為我不去追高
你看股票不追高 每天在漲停
每天都說漲停的你相信喔
你這樣很容易受傷
你看陽明一拉又說有了
跌下去又不講了 我又出掉了
我進來 我出掉了 你相信喔
不要傻了啦 好不好
來 你要的是真正紅的分析師
你看 我昨天有沒有
我昨天說
昨天誰買誰買台灣股市有沒有看到
搜尋新聞你看喔
郭哲榮背後推手有沒有看到
昨天驚天逆轉誰在買 有沒有
誰在偷偷買有沒有看到
這是我們的專欄
你看一個新聞 兩個新聞
有沒有在講 沒有錯吧
Yahoo新聞也有 一天以內喔
三立新聞 郭哲榮揭誰在偷買
我的標題 昨天的標題就是誰偷買
節目標題就是這樣
節目封面就是這樣
助理給我節目封面
誰偷買 三立新聞也報導
經濟新聞也報導
Yahoo股市也報導
投資長哪一天哈啾一下
可能也有人報導
哲哲就是紅啊 能怎麼辦
然後東森新聞也有報導
台股昨日驚天逆轉
誰在買有沒有看到
郭哲榮揭背後推手有沒有看到
東森財經新聞也報導
我還看到他的推播
一個什麼三立 東森
Yahoo 經濟日報
大家都報導
我要再寫個專欄
工商時報還找我寫專欄
我實在太忙了
我再寫個專欄還是可以再上新聞
這些都不用花錢
紅啊
你要了解這個邏輯
我再講一次今年5萬點
我今天看
我今天是賺1400多萬
助理每天要給我看0050賺多少錢
0050我才幾天的時間
賺1400多萬
誰偷買嘛 是不是
我昨天的標題就是這個
誰偷買有沒有
尾盤拉千點誰偷買有沒有
三個 四個新聞在報導我
再看一次
東森財經有沒有看到
誰在買 誰偷買有沒有看到
沒錯吧
昨天狂拉1000點誰在買 有沒有
然後Yahoo誰在買
郭哲榮有沒有看到
郭哲榮告訴你
經濟日報誰在買 有沒有看到
三立新聞誰在買
所以你可以想像
那時候0050我買1億的時候
有幾十則新聞報導
0050買了1億隔一天後
馬上漲停板
又有幾十篇報導
你不找台灣最紅的分析師 你要找誰
我今天隨隨便便啦
不要每天一直講賺錢 不賺錢
我就算不講
還是一堆人參加我的會員
人在做天在看 懂不懂
你要的是這樣的分析師
助理幫我算了
0050我賺了快1400萬
1390萬
來 我跟大家問好
等一下再跟你講趙建銘的故事 好不好
他們買0050是對的嗎
跟大家打招呼一下
看一下喔 來
瑤姐賣掉國巨
那個做很短 賣掉國巨不重要 來
哲哲沒有義務解答你們的問題
因為不是會員
我不會講那麼直接
我會說資本主義的市場
我一定是以會員服務為主
沒有就是沒有付錢的
然後又要完美的服務
沒有這回事 好不好 OK嗎
我們還是要養工作人員啊 是不是
我又不收業配 是不是
多少投信找我做業配
我又不收
總是要收會員吧 OK 來
今天海水退了 交易量變多了
淹水退了 來
國巨真的要死了
國巨跟環球晶就是這樣
就是籌碼亂
我跟你講啦
怎樣死也不是
國巨要死也不是我死啦
這邊你就買
沒有理由破這個底好不好
記憶體會缺
我覺得你們很奇怪
1200跟500的國巨
其實基本面沒有差很多
我再講一次
1200跟500的國巨
其實基本面沒有差很多
這就是股市好玩的地方
這就是AI沒辦法取代人類的地方
股市有時候不理性
AI的邏輯很好
但是不知道為什麼人類那麼不理性
1200跟500元 我問你
昨天看到巴逆逆說
對不起我不該推薦你
50倍槓桿的虛擬貨幣
你們用AI
如果用AI是直接問AI怎麼買股票
你們會很慘 會死定了
所以我說AI沒辦法取代投資
因為你在問問題的時候
你們已經有答案了
你問AI 你一定要請他中立的回答
不是順著你的想法
這個我的男朋友是不是王八蛋
我告訴你 那個AI一定說是啊
你聽了有比較開心嗎
你要中立的想法
感情的事我不講
這個很複雜
前陣子哲哲化身為感情大師嘛 對不對
我要講的是說你要用AI
你要中立的問他
你懂不懂 不是這個要不要買
AI很難取代投資的啦
所以我們分析師還可以活一陣子啦
好不好 OK
我可以活很久啦 好不好 來
國巨財報還不錯
就是聖誕樹被陳泰銘嚇到
我早就被陳泰銘嚇到了
所以我買500多塊OK
小哲Baby
你叫我Baby
寶貝跟baby
雖然都是一樣意思
但是聽起來不太對
日本的被動一樣很慘
兩件事
日本的被動也會被台灣的被動怎麼樣
影響到啊
我愛你越久越被動
來 導播 Ready go
愛你越久我越被動
只因你的愛居無定所
居無定所啊 好不好
一會日本 一會台灣
這都互相影響的 OK嗎
互相影響的 好不好
你看 互相影響 來
根據鏡週刊的報導
他們離婚是250612 什麼意思
2025年6月12號是不是
那時候0050還沒分割
2300萬放到現在是翻倍了
一年多的時間就翻倍了
所以你看喔
今天這個第三點喔
我們來看一下
看0050的八卦 你就知道說
0050 因為趙建銘到現在
因為陳幸妤也知道
親愛的我再也回不去了
他們覺得愛已經回不去了
陳幸妤有愛他
但是他知道回不去了
趙建銘至少要還他2300萬
是兒子的教育基金嘛 對不對
他說還2300萬有什麼用
6年的時間
被兒子吐槽
買0050都翻倍了
不只翻倍 6年應該翻3倍以上
這是6年的時間 有沒有
直接連兒子都知道喔
兒子還不是做股票的
買0050都翻倍
他也說 陳幸妤說他不會投資
買ETF也賺錢
就有網友試算出來
如果當初真的拿去投資0050
3年後資產恐破8000萬
有那麼多嗎
那都是選最低到最高
有可能啦
因為曾經17000
曾經滄海難為水
不要亂造句
曾經17000 18000
去年4月的時候有沒有 清明時節
這都是一樣
航運股為什麼這次我不會上當
都是記憶在我腦袋裡面
哲哲看起來很年輕
但是我有30年投資經驗
我100多萬粉絲每天在監督我
我怎麼能不成長
你不找我 你找誰
就算是財經娛樂節目
我也是最好看的 是不是
買0050翻倍了
你看我也是念茲在茲
你不參加我的會員
買0050也可以啊
而且我這本書講過了
現在大家都知道0050
國民ETF 我20年前講的時候
我當分析師講的時候 我菜鳥的時候
還被投顧公司的副總說
郭哲榮講這個ETF你不會紅啊
你到底要不要收會員
不講漲停板
我根本不理他
I don't care
我跟你講我這個人就這樣子
我超級反骨的
我覺得做對的事
我才不理任何人
我走出我自己的一條道路了
全台灣現在我最紅
從頭到尾叫你抱到尾了
你抱一輩子啦
所以現在0053你知道嗎
也是元大的ETF
那時候我遇到他們投顧的
投信的總經理
他說他們現在慢慢要推
有那種台灣50
然後推那種就是不發利息的
因為你們要有新的觀念
記得以後會有新的觀念
利息不發 股利是假的
你要就直接賣
你賣零股就好了嘛
所以我說台灣政府
我希望台灣證交所 我再次呼籲
很簡單 因為台積電以後會越來越貴
到時候以後到1萬塊怎麼辦
不是不可能啦
我要看10萬點耶
10萬點台積電至少要5000塊
5000塊一個人500萬買不起
可是如果你5000塊
以後一次買是買1股
你會覺得貴嗎
你買1張是500萬
你買1股是5000塊
你就覺得台積電不貴
當你覺得台積電不貴的時候
還會促進交易量
還會促進稅收
懂嗎 真的要趕快把制度改了
我一定要一直講
我這個有利於
我不是在嗆主管機關
我是為大家好
我這個人都是這樣
我做生意都是
Win win situation
一定要改成像美國的制度
改零股制度就很簡單了
現在已經慢慢銜接了
趕快改 真的我希望大家
真的去反映這個事情
改了以後台灣股市還會上去
成交量還會起來
業界的人都會賺錢
就是因為本業賺錢 因為交易量變大
當然比較容易賺錢
我講的是說生意會賺錢
所以你看
哪有分析師跟你講這些東西
我今天也可以跟你講精材
精材又怎麼樣 漲停板怎樣
其實說好賺也好賺
說不好賺也不好賺
他現在就是來來回回
可是精材你看
我說是不是裡面有大戶
法說這麼爛
看起來本益比很高
結果拉起來
我講得很簡單嘛
台積電資本支出概念股
什麼6187萬潤
可以1000多塊
以前100多塊我被人家罵死
萬潤去年的時候才2 300塊
為什麼精材不能飆
當他們訂單滿的時候
你就知道很恐怖了
就跟6488環球晶一樣
你看6488環球晶有沒有看到
投信還在買
投信 你剛才說誰賣
00981A我沒有管他好不好
他要做短讓他做短
你現在討論他做很短
不好意思 來看一下我的名言
哲哲有那麼短嗎
我看很長啊 各位
為什麼環球晶我沒有要出 為什麼
我不要那種
我今天買 我明天賣
有人討論00981A 他做很短
我不要做這種事
偶一為之 但是我不會常常為之
為什麼 因為有些會員
有些是20幾歲的 動作很快
有些是80幾歲的 動作很慢
我希望讓你們通通能賺到
那前提是你要能買得到
你買到後
結果我今天叫你買 明天叫你出
不對 有人明天才買
我都替你們想
就像一樣啊
很多人問我為什麼不買台灣50正2
我早就賺3000萬 4000萬了
為什麼
我今天賺差不多1400萬
不是快3000萬嗎
如果用正2的話
2倍啦 他平均是1.5倍 扯遠了
2倍大概3000萬啦
假設是2倍 台灣50正2
因為我有社會責任啊
看我的人那麼多
100個人裡面
有一個人因為這樣子
跟不上我的腳步 我就算了
我少賺一點沒關係
你久了就知道
哲哲少賺一點
哲哲是心情派的
業界同仁
業界分析師攻擊我 我都笑笑的
第一次笑 第二次忍耐
第三次 第四 第五次
我該攻擊
那就是1年 2年 3年
100萬 200萬 300萬
律師費 該花的律師 該花的廣告
應該說該花的律師費我一毛都不省
沒在跟你開玩笑的
你久了才知道
哲哲真的是
原來他真的沒那麼在乎錢
他在乎這些感覺
我沒有一定要你參加我的會員
隨便啦 開心就好了
真的 你覺得認同我再參加我的會員
你知道嗎 就是這樣子
OK嗎 這個跟大家講
攻擊哲哲有什麼用
把自己身體搞差了 業績變差了
財報都看得到 是不是
視網膜剝離
心血管還堵塞要開大刀
我還是祝福那位張姓分析師
真的沒必要
毀掉哲哲並不會增加你的業績
事實證明了
身體也不一定會變好 何必呢
賺錢還是要享受人生 我祝福他
只是何必呢
早知如此 何必這樣子呢
其實我做什麼事 我都會提醒對方
不要這樣做
因為哲哲
你們知不知道我昨天
我2點多
我還在處理那個律師函的事情
我就是要贏
就算我輸 我也要讓對方知道
哲哲絕對是毅力驚人 不好惹
這就是我的個性
其實我是個鬥犬你知道嗎
可是我年紀越大
我覺得不要當鬥犬 這樣不好
可是對方要逼我當鬥犬
我比較想要把鬥犬的精神
到股市裡面你知道嗎
所以我也不喜歡參加選股比賽
我一參加選股比賽 我要得第一
我輸了我又很生氣 你知道嗎
選股比賽
可是通常我都會得第一
我就是留點機會給別人
我就是這種人
健康不好又要告人的
大家應該都知道哪一位
不要幫他打廣告 就是這樣子
他是告了我以後健康不好
這個業界都知道的事情
可是我還是希望他健健康康 好不好
每天一定要講個5分鐘
因為你知道為什麼要講嗎
因為業界都在看我的節目
我要提醒他們不要再來鬧了 好不好
真的不要鬧了
真的沒有比較好 來
貸款也要告
對啦 我是這種人
但是我現在不用貸款了 好啦
扯遠了 每次2分鐘提醒同業
祝他們賺錢
各位同業賺錢好不好
我們魚幫水 水幫魚
扯遠了 不講了
國巨要不要噴
我不管00981A要不要賣不賣
我跟你講都會拉
你知道為什麼我今年業績好
因為我不喜歡追高
來啦 2377
你看微星什麼死樣子
創新高主力玩你 又殺下去
今年量沒有出來之前
不要亂追高
來 跟我一起唸
量沒有出來前 來
量沒有出來前 不要追高
是不是 不錯
導播很有Fu
就不要追高嘛 是不是
哲哲受傷很深才會無法放下
其實真的
應該這樣講
一般的分析師應該會搞到憂鬱症
超級憂鬱症
我是毅力很堅強的
我是想到說
我一定要喝止這個業界的歪風
不然就是網路
都是同業在故意攻擊人
都是歪風 來
只會分析分析師的分析師
只能得0分
對啊 分析師要做業績
就是做股票
做股票啊 各位
要做股票
績效好怎麼會怕沒會員
績效好怎麼可能會沒會員
績效好怎麼可能不會業績前幾名
這想也知道
會員介紹都介紹不完了
我們來看一下
今天3035智原為什麼拉起來
這就是IC設計 好不好
今天IC設計還有IP股特別強
你看創意6000塊了
創意為什麼6000塊 很恐怖
創意居然創新高
我記得 你看創意
所以IC設計股本比較輕
所以我今天如果是中實戶
我會拉IC設計是有道理的
其來有自
還有TPU概念股 ASIC
就是說我不要用輝達的通用晶片
AI通用晶片
我用專用晶片
專屬於我的
這個跟大家講
可是我真的覺得輝達的晶片還是比較好
因為我本來以為Gemini狂贏
現在基本上
你知道嗎 我去年不是說
去年記得我一句話
去年就是那句話
讓我覺得台灣股市會到36000
你要記得一件事
那時候只有我喊36000
還有別的財經台主持人
在他的Threads上面寫說
哲哲這麼敢喊
他不是批評我
他就是說只有我敢喊那麼大聲
然後我說36000甚至40000
大家不相信
你看轉眼間都已經快50000了
那時候我的想法就是
因為在11月的時候
在我生日那時候
11月20幾號的時候
21號左右
公布了Google的Gemini程式
就是AI程式
我說在Gemini面前
ChatGPT是垃圾
現在我要倒回來
在ChatGPT面前Gemini是垃圾
為什麼
學如逆水行舟 不進則退
不是Gemini變差了
而是ChatGPT太強了
Gemini有點變差 變笨了
所以真的很缺記憶體
所以你們說記憶體怎麼會死
那真的笨到不行 你知道嗎
我每天都在用 你知道嗎
我任何事情都用它
我不能一直跟你們講太多
講太多到時候
商業模式學起來就算了
因為我當分析師
比如說我可以教你說
你們可以去串聯
API串聯那個語音模式
然後去跟各大餐廳合作
一個月收個1000塊也可以
以後有這種合作方式
可是我不能跟你講
我教分析師怎麼用
怎麼做研究分析
怎麼分析自己 怎麼分析節目
講下去同業都會學
他可以做很多事情
來 這個跟大家講
射手座嗎 我是射手座
Gemini真的很爛
今年變得很爛 你知道嗎 來
南茂請問哲哲大GG幫我們分析嗎
你都這樣講 我能不分析嗎
不要開玩笑 我不分析啦
南茂我不知道代碼多少
講一下D-Day嗎
那個D-Day沒怎麼樣嘛
川普就是很會取名字 你知道嗎
他很適合當分析師你知道嗎
帥哥哲 眼鏡可不可以換圓形的看看
你們好問題耶
圓形的
因為我已經老人家 圓形的看看
圓形的大陸比較紅這個好不好
Gemini最近很爛
ChatGPT比較好用
對啊 是不是
就是缺記憶體嘛
國巨散戶太多根本上不出去
沒錯 所以你們每週要看一下
國巨的散戶數量有沒有減少
至少要減個8萬到10萬
你才有機會突破700元 記起來
從這邊高峰50萬嘛
減個8萬到10萬
才有機會突破700元
記起來好不好 OK嗎
夜盤上46 什麼46
46000了 看一下夜盤
早知如此
也沒什麼 漲40幾點而已
你們數學可不可以
漲40幾點 以為漲了400多點
華邦電已經在吃貨
我說華邦電也不錯啊
華邦電慢慢拉起來
華邦電有拉啦
記憶體還是OK的啦 好不好
相信哲哲有跌就買環球晶
對 沒有錯
但是你不要全部重壓
100%好不好
穎崴 不要 我不要講那麼多股票
不要一直
一個人只能丟3次
頂多丟2次同樣的訊息
丟太多次不行
國巨不大跌怎麼清除散戶
在洗啦
輝達的財報怎麼看
我們先看一下明天輝達的財報
來 講輝達的財報之前
哲哲先喝個水 來
喝個水的時候
先恭賀我們精材的簡訊
今天精材是不是漲停
快漲停還是漲停
快漲停 340元有沒有
快漲停有沒有看到 漂亮吧
念一下 導播先念一下
3 2 1
好 8月26號禮拜三 今天的簡訊
恭喜3374精材
股價大漲超過7%
準備再戰近期新高
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺74%
我持續看好它
手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
導播你好像比較有氣無力
快感冒是不是 有一點
有一點喔
沒關係 那導播再講
休息一下沒關係
等一下再講
精材你看今天大漲7%
你要的就是這樣的分析師嘛
是不是 講輝達財報 明天講一下
輝達財報過去公布好像都是跌
你知道嗎 都是跌
看一下
但是我還想說Jackson Hole
以前我認識這個名詞的時候
以前的時候
幾年前 10幾年前
聽到這個Jackson Hole
想說傑克森是誰
他的洞 什麼他的洞很奇怪
是在裡面開會還是怎麼樣
Jackson Hole
其實全球央行年會 所以很重要
這個Fed都不會講什麼話
而且這一次Fed
還要減少開會了
感覺話就很少
他就是不想讓你猜到
所以我覺得中性偏鷹 偏鴿
都不重要
雖然有些分析師說這個很重要
我認為不重要
他不會講什麼
那我們來看一下
看一下這個輝達財報
比較重要好不好
輝達財報就像我講的 來
輝達業績預測
輝達敢漲價
那你至少不要讓客戶抱怨
你明年還敢漲價
再漲價15%
最近剛漲價好像70% 很扯
請問你 人家會不會受不了
不會 馬斯克說
輝達的晶片還是最好的
馬斯克很敢花錢
馬斯克是那種
你那個秘書要跟他漲價
然後他想一想以後
沒有 我不漲你價
你去別的地方
你調到別的地方去
他就沒有需要秘書了
他連秘書的錢都省了
他這麼省的人
可是他願意買輝達的晶片
你懂不懂 他秘書說他要加薪
他就說那你一段時間
我試驗一下一段時間需不需要你
發現不需要他了
他說那你要不要離開
或者是我把你調到別的地方去
他連這種錢都省了
然後也沒有真正買房子給自己住
都住很普通的地方
然後這麼有錢的人 這麼節省的人
結果願意買輝達的晶片
你就知道了嘛 是不是
人家是覺得輝達的東西好
所以第二季的營收增幅96%
重點是第三季
1037億會不會再增加
他預估EPS 2.36
這兩個數字就好了 好不好
我覺得都有機會再增加一點點
中間值再高一點點 好不好
所以第三季是1037億
有沒有再高
明天凌晨的時候
是4點半還是5點半
助理告訴我正確時間 查一下
順便也問一下AI 都查
明天什麼時間
2.36 EPS
美元的2.36 美股EPS
還有1037億
我覺得有機會比他高
因為他是中位數而已
中間值 OK
然後有人說要閉著眼睛買 好不好
黃仁勳快閃台北 禮拜天來嘛
來只是買包子而已
有人說要見台積電
按照我的消息
應該說按照我的推測
2個小時見什麼台積電
吃飯也來不及
沒有人吃飯2個小時的
你還要下去 還要上來
所以他真的是來買包子的 你知道嗎
來 買包子還買肉粽
樂觀派外資代表
他為什麼要買包子 買肉粽
我知道了
比較好帶有沒有發現到 是不是
比較好帶
樂觀派的外資代表都說
目標價280到345元
所以Rubin的產能到底可不可以
之前不是說產能有問題
生產有問題
看起來我都覺得有可能沒問題 好不好
財務融資的方式
我覺得他會
融資會比想像中再少一點點
因為大家都會擔心他的財務狀況
重點是這個營收中間值 下一季
應該說本季 本季的營收
1037億有機會增加
預估EPS 2.36有機會增加好不好
來吧 所以
那增加完以後呢
增加是一回事喔
第一個 有沒有比我的預測好
有沒有比華爾街預測好
我回答Yes
那回答Yes以後股市一定會增加嗎
不一定 那我覺得我還是偏向於偏多
因為有人說 為什麼說閉著眼睛買
24倍本益比已經是一個區間下緣了
就是很少24倍本益比 懂嗎
所以輝達財報應該不錯好不好 OK
記得我說這句話
明天凌晨4點20分公布
聯發科已跌多日
今天26號聯發科漲210元
我沒有 我從頭到尾
我沒有看壞聯發科
你不要說4000元才講
第一個 沒有4000元
我只是不喜歡外資在漲了3倍以後
才跟你講說1萬元
你看害死多少人
邏輯是說他一定TPU晶片
一定會增加很多
聽聽就好 AI市場會大規模增大 增幅
不代表他們一定需要找聯發科
去製造TPU晶片
他不是獨佔
他不像台積電
我AI規模擴大 對不起
我要找先進製程 我只能找台積電
我告訴你這3年
甚至5年你買台積電很穩
甚至有機會勝過台灣50
可是我還是要推薦台灣50
因為不只是100個裡面
我不要一個人聽錯或動作慢
我還要的是你看我的節目10年
再驗證我的說法
我要你節目20年再驗證我的說法
等到我7 80歲的時候
你再驗證我的說法
發現郭哲榮原來是對大家最好的
懂嗎 什麼都不懂就買台灣50
再買一個00662
那斯達克ETF 就這樣就好了
這是我幾十年一個最穩的頓悟
如果你想要穩的
你想要刺激呢
那就一部分參加我的會員
一部分買這些啦 真的
大家久了
我很多會員粉絲都是看我的節目看很久的
都參加我的會員參加很久的
不然怎麼100多萬
怎麼140萬人
下午 大家不用工作是不是
又不是說晚上或凌晨
唯一這麼多粉絲的 好不好 OK
這陣子就只有你看多還大勝利
對啊 只有我看多
從頭到尾看多 是不是 來
哲哲全台最硬最大蟒蛇
南茂是8150
你一會叫我寶貝 一會叫我蟒蛇
你真是無所不用其極
技術線型還好啦
沒有到很好也沒到很差 這樣可以嗎
南茂我沒那麼了解 不要亂講
我只能看技術線型而已好不好
沒有到很好也沒到很差
這支股票本來就牛皮 你是不是不會看
很牛皮的股票啦
這有點像帆宣你知道嗎 很牛皮啊
帆宣今天也不錯
可是今天不錯代表好嗎
你看是不是
你看 我看技術線型是不是兩個很像
打第二隻腳
第二隻腳離前低有點近
但不會太近
南茂跟帆宣很像嘛
看久了股票覺得差不多
就是不會動的股票 懂不懂
如果你鴻海受不了
那你也不能買這種
也不能買南茂 好不好
鴻海為什麼OK
因為台灣股市今天量出來啦
是不是比前幾天出來的多
量是不是出來了
你看出來了
加權指數的成分股
就有機會拉起來
就這麼簡單而已啊
That's all 沒有那麼難
不要把他想得太複雜好不好 來
然後南亞科也是慢慢拉啦
記憶體沒辦法
記憶體還是主流 主軸啦 好不好
3532台勝科都拉了
你現在問我
台勝科就是二線的
你要一線的你還是要環球晶
你不要緊張啦
可能我講環球晶講太大力了
有人故意要甩轎或怎樣
你都平常心
5483中美晶
這個沒什麼
這個沒什麼好不好 平常心好不好
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
我不去事後話 不去馬後炮
然後我們看一下什麼股票
5347世界先進
差不多 好不好
這些股票 今天應該講完了吧
今天剩幾分鐘
36 想早點結束你覺得怎樣
股票差不多啦 都講完了
我看AI圖 我AI圖做很多
你不要看我啦
其實我講2小時都可以
你看我AI圖做這麼多
這個輝達財報 這邊還可以講
不用講了
趙建銘 你看連趙建銘的兒子
大兒子與父對質1小時我都做AI圖
不知道 細節不需要
反正你媽媽吵2300萬
我就還你2300萬 跟他兒子這樣講
都做成AI圖 很無聊
9月IPO啦
IPO就是那個Anthropic
募資1000億美元
這個也會吸資
也會吸一些股市資金
2021年光IPO就吸了股市資金大概5兆
現在已經超過5兆了
OK嗎 我講的是台幣
他講的是美元
1560億美元
Anthropic也看一下好不好
Anthropic也是突然轉正的
因為他們是B2B還B2C
他們最主要是跟企業客戶收錢
跟一般散戶收錢很難收啦 懂不懂
跟一般散戶收錢是要賺廣告費用
賺什麼 我看你的軟體
然後你去跟那些打廣告的人收費用
OK嗎
所以還是跟企業收錢比較OK 好不好
這是價格彈性的問題啦
有些人對價格比較敏感
企業客戶對價格比較敏感
講太多我怕你知道我太多
你會喜歡我
沒有啦 扯遠了
哲哲這個都是2 30年的經驗啦
股市經驗30年了 OK
最強的機櫃嘛
Grog 3 LPX嘛
這個沒什麼
他就是為了AI agent好不好
AI agent也可以 慢慢來
AI agent也可以 以後也需要
這個跟大家講
推算 推算
美債殖利率
最後跟大家講
網路邀請有沒有看到
哲哲講話s178178
有人故意用截圖有沒有
AI修改截圖叫你要加LINE
我不會主動叫你加LINE
還沒有熟的情況下
我不會主動叫你加什麼LINE不LINE
我就不缺業績了
加什麼LINE
LINE要加就加@s178
然後用@s178的名義
或者用我那個IG及Threads的名義
告訴你再加另外一個LINE
不會有這回事好不好
這是截圖 這是修改圖
亂修改好不好
我還是要強調一件事
為什麼這次我們算不嚴重
剛剛那個股票真恐怖
等到你醒來的時候 你追漲停 你看
這幾天追你都賠大錢
來不及 大戶 中實戶就是賺你一根而已
賺你一兩根 就拉起來
漲了5 6天 漲真的喔
今天一根跌停板什麼都沒了
今年現在目前為止我請你不要追高
今年我績效那麼好就是不追高
不追高 盡量不追高
講起來很簡單 做起來很難
就像我講啊
趙建銘他兒子吐槽爸爸
你2300萬元搞投資
買台灣50都賺一倍了
那為什麼趙建銘沒賺
沉不住氣嘛
你看元大台灣50
你看這幾天有動嗎
如果你只看這幾天 來
沒錯吧 從7月到現在
根本沒動啊
從105到現在 105到109
根本沒動 100元到這邊
到107元這邊根本沒動啊
沒錯吧 這一段根本沒動啊
那你看我就沉住氣在這邊買
在那邊買了以後是不是
你看是不是在這邊買 沒錯吧
93元這附近 我記得93元
我在這邊買 你看
一下子就拉到100元
拉到107元
最高107差不多
投資朋友 機會是等來的
大部分的行情就是這麼無聊
趙建銘可能就忍受不了這個無聊嘛
我忍受得了
你受不了這個無聊看我的節目
其實台灣50
這樣3年來個快3倍
你不覺得很扯嗎
漲到快3倍 賺到快3倍
可是事實擺在眼前
可是大部分時間他是很無聊
他是很Boring的
你要忍住 沉住氣啊
大部分股票是這樣 飆股是等來的
跟我講一遍
飆股是等來的
等來的 真的是等來的好不好
無聊就多看我的節目啦
今年到時候會突破5萬啦
我不敢說100分啦 我不敢說100啦
但是我跟你講 我覺得機率很高啦
趙建銘應該沒有參加投資長的會員
沒關係 我沒有要求
有些很紅的人
要參加我的會員我都說No no no
我真的 之前很多人參加我的會員
不要勉強
有些朋友
哲哲我看你的面子上參加我的會員
千萬不要 我都跟他們說千萬不要
鄰居或什麼千萬不要 不要鬧
不缺業績 不需要
飆股等來的 對不對
趙建銘臉饅化
我知道啦 有些人講臉饅化
就是那個玻尿酸打多
不是玻尿酸 洢蓮絲打多了
膠原蛋白增生
增生完以後就不行嘛
還有人說那個跟羅志祥一樣
臉饅頭化 叫臉饅化
打太多這個膠原蛋白
太多也不行 太少也不行
打太多就沒有高級感
有時候瘦一點點比較好
你看這邊我凹了就有那個高級感
怎麼辦 為什麼臉饅頭化我都知道
臉饅化你看一下
不好意思我什麼都看
你叫我講歷史也可以 我都講
幫我分析力旺
智原好強
智原就是慢慢等嘛 好不好
我送趙建銘3個月免費會員
我才不送免費會員
我不送任何會員 我為什麼要送
你跟我說鼎泰豐會送人家試吃嗎
拜託一下
我比鼎泰豐還鼎泰豐 股市鼎很豐
不要鬧 送人家幹什麼
來 自然老去最帥 好不好
Lily禮拜四會再來 再來錄影
投資朋友 重點還是在我身上 來
這個跟大家講
台海戰爭買那斯達克ETF有沒有用
當然有用
為什麼沒有用
因為戰爭就要把你的錢沒收喔 對不對
要花錢才有身價 好啦
鼎泰豐有140萬粉絲嗎
這個我不知道
來 對 頂太瘋
我是股價鼎泰豐 這個頂太瘋 來
哲女郎 我說真的
就是以後我真的會少用哲女郎啦
或是說不用哲女郎
因為哲哲
我覺得哲哲自己的要求比較高啦
我覺得不是每個人一定跟得上我的腳步
我覺得這樣也不好
這個跟大家講
好啦 扯遠了 還是股票啦
結束了 你在廁所裡面
看我的節目對不對 廁所不出來
可以 廁所可以出來了 好不好 來
這個跟大家講 來
好奇哲媽分析師有推薦股票 什麼意思
來 我們來看一下
最後要講什麼事情
元大台灣50
飆股是等來的
差不多 現在43分了
明天那個Anthropic
央行年會
趙建銘2300萬早就翻倍了
等來的 0050也是等來的
0050漲那麼慢都是等來的
飆股也是等來的 不要想太多
財報 下季預期營收1037億元
我覺得可能會超乎預期好了
股價也有機會拉起來
好不好 差不多講完了
然後空單83000
之前說空單很重要 我說沒有
外資這幾年空單根本不重要
以前空單有重要 現在空單不重要
今天剛好46000
而且現在是正價差
今天期貨漲了快1000點左右
這個一度啊
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師好不好
精材今天也是恭喜的簡訊
有沒有看到
精材有沒有 大賺74%
這是實在的績效
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
想清楚了 想明白了
趕快來電洽詢
全台灣最紅的分析師不是我 是誰
我們績效也真的很好啊
今天有一堆股票在拉啊
帆宣啊 精材在拉
群聯也有點小拉
這就是你要的分析師
可是等到大拉的時候
你再去追
你就會像航運股一樣被修理
現在的台股適合低接
所以趁現在很多股票還在低檔的時候
用力的跟我一起進場
我們一起來賺大錢
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
趕快加入我們的行列
哲哲努力來幫你賺大錢
謝謝各位 Byebye